serial killers evil spirits and plenty
of giant explosions these are the flicks
that you won't want to miss in 2023
warning this video contains Fast
Flashing images viewer discretion is
advised especially for those with
photosensitive epilepsy
like his previous film old which is
based on a Swiss graphic novel M Night
Shyamalan will turn to some interesting
Source material for his next film in the
summer of 2022 it was revealed that
knock at the cabin shyamalan's upcoming
Thriller is based on Paul tremblay's
horror novel The Cabin at the end of the
world though we don't yet know how
shyamalan's version of the tale will
twist The Narrative the cabin at the end
of the world follows a couple and their
daughter as they're set upon by a group
of mysterious armed strangers at their
secluded cabin the Invaders claim that
one member of this small family must be
sacrificed in order to save the world
leading to a tense standoff with
unimaginable consequences shyamalan's
film stars Jonathan Groff Ben Aldridge
and Kristen sway as the family in danger
along with Dave Batista Rupert Grint
Nikki amuka bird and Abby Quinn as the
home Invaders expect to see some truly
chilling horror when knock at the cabin
arrives February 3rd 2023
the mcu's Multiverse Saga began with
Spider-Man no way home and Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness but
things are about to get deadly serious
in the upcoming Ant-Man and the WASP
Quantum mania this time around Scott
Lang and his allies will team up to face
Kang the Conqueror a multiversal
time-traveling villain played by
Lovecraft country star Jonathan Majors
Majors first played the role in the form
of a character dubbed simply he who
remains at the end of Loki season 1 and
now he's returning to play another
variant of the mysterious adversary
exactly what Kang wants and how Scott
will end up facing him is still a
mystery what's not a mystery is that our
heroes will definitely be spending a lot
of time in the quantum realm where
they'll run into a character played by
Bill Murray one of Marvel's weirdest
villains the evil oversized head called
Modoc will also be showing up we'll find
out exactly what happens next when
Quantum media hits theaters on February
17th 2023
see you soon
back in 2015 the world of Rocky Balboa
expanded with Creed in which the
legendary boxer decides to coach the son
of his late friend and rival starring
Michael B Jordan as Adonis Creed the
Ryan coogler directed Sports drama was a
major success earning Sylvester Stallone
his first Golden Globe in 2023 the Creed
franchise is set to continue with its
third installment building on the first
sequel in which Adonis fought the son of
Ivan Drago this time around Jordan
himself will also be stepping into the
director's seat giving him even more
ownership of the sub-franchise he helped
launch Tessa Thompson and Felicia Rashad
will also return as adonis's girlfriend
and stepmother respectively but one
person who won't be back is Stallone
himself with Rocky Balboa's Journey
seemingly wrapped up at the end of Creed
2 it looks like the Italian Stallion is
done at least for now across from Jordan
in the ring will be Jonathan Majors who
will serve as a new antagonist for the
series Adonis will enter the ring once
again when Creed 3 drops on March 3rd
2023 Dungeons and Dragons has long been
one of the biggest names in fantasy so
it makes sense that a new attempt at an
adaptation of the franchise will be
reaching Cinemas in 2023. Dungeons and
Dragons honor among Thieves from Game
Night Riders John Francis Daly and
Jonathan Goldstein looks like it has the
makings of a clever fantasy Adventure
honor among Thieves will follow a group
of well thieves as they set out to stop
an apocalyptic event that they
inadvertently caused by stealing a
dangerous artifact going on this Quest
will be actors Chris Pine Michelle
Rodriguez Sofia lillis Justin Smith and
reggae Jean page of course plenty of
iconic creatures from the role-playing
game will be making appearances from owl
Bears to mimics to gelatinous cubes
Dungeons and Dragons honor among Thieves
sneaks into theaters also on March 3rd
2023
in the spring of 2023 four years after
Shazam burst into theaters we'll finally
get a sequel from many of the same
people who made the first film so fun at
the end of 2019's Shazam Billy Batson
gained a family of Heroes to help him in
his quest to save the world say my name
no not my name no the say the name that
I say to turn into this guy
now the world is threatened again and
the family will face a challenge unlike
anything they've seen before instead of
a mad scientist Shazam and friends will
face off against the daughters of Atlas
played by Helen Mirren Lucy Liu and
Rachel zegler many of the original
players from the first film are also
back for the second installment
including Jack Dylan Grazer as Freddie
Freeman and jimin hansu as the wizard
Shazam we can expect another epic good
time but don't yet know how this film
will connect with Dwayne Johnson's Black
Adam another major player in the Shazam
Saga regardless Shazam Fury of the Gods
hits theaters on March 17 2023
how good to see you again so soon Mr
Wick
shall I announce you
yes please we were supposed to get the
fourth chapter of the John Wick Saga
back in 2021 but the kova 19 pandemic
pushed things back a bit now we know
that the spring of 2023 will finally
bring us the next phase of the
Assassin's ever-growing story we don't
know all that much about where chapter 4
will take John so far other than the
clues left by the end of chapter 3. we
do know of course that Keanu Reeves will
return in the title role along with Ian
McShane as Winston Lance Reddick as
Sharon and Lawrence Fishburne as the
Bowery King newcomers to the John Wick
Universe include Don Yen Clancy Brown
Bill Skarsgard Rena salayama and
hiroyuki Sonata John Wick will return
When chapter 4 hits theaters on March
24th 2023. a decade away from the box
office didn't Stomp The Fifth
installment of the scream franchise from
being a box office hit it wasn't long
before a sixth film was announced we
don't know much about Scream 6 just yet
but filmmakers have revealed that
Melissa Barrera Jenna Ortega Jasmine
Savoy Brown and Mason Gooding will all
reprise their roles from the 2022 recoil
they'll be joined by franchise Mainstay
Courtney Cox and scream 4's hidden
Panettiere sadly the biggest star of the
franchise Nev Campbell will not be
returning as Sydney Prescott after a pay
dispute it'll be strange to lose Sydney
but Samara weaving and Tony revillori
will be there to round out the cast in
her absence Scream 6 will be Unleashed
on March 31st 2023
After the Dark Universe experiment
failed with the mummy in 2017 Universal
Pictures set out to craft a new approach
to its classic movie Monsters giving us
films like the Invisible Man in the
process now they're taking some of their
characters down a very different route
with Renfield a movie about one of the
most famous Sidekicks in Horror history
directed by Chris McKay and starring
Nicholas Holt in the title role Renfield
will tell the story of Count Dracula's
servant who gets a new lease on life and
a chance at his own agency when he falls
in love with a traffic cop and sets off
on an unlikely Journey if that doesn't
sound fun enough Renfield will feature
the one and only Nicholas Cage playing
Count Dracula a dream role for the
legendary actor Renfield arrives in all
its vampiric glory on April 14 2023 a
decade after the Evil Dead franchise got
a Reboot film from director fide Alvarez
Sam raimi's deadites are set to once
again Rampage through movie theaters in
Evil Dead rise this time around the
action will moved to a Los Angeles
apartment building where a reunion
between two sisters is interrupted by an
ancient book unleashing The deadites the
film marks the first time an evil dead
film will take things to a more urban
setting which should be an interesting
change of pace writer director Lee
Cronin is responsible for this new take
on the franchise now with Sam Raimi and
Bruce Campbell acting as executive
producers it's time to see what Cronin
can do with the deadites evil deadrise
invades theaters on April 21st 2023
groovy
foreign
said back in 2017 that he would be back
for a third installment in the Guardians
of the Galaxy series but we didn't know
then that the weight would be this long
it's been a bit of a bumpy road Gunn was
fired and eventually rehired by Marvel
but now Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
seems to finally be on course a sneak
peek at San Diego Comic-Con 2022 teased
tension between Star-Lord and Gamora as
well as an origin story for Rocket
Raccoon in addition to all The Usual
Suspects volume 3 will also feature
Maria bakalova as Cosmo the space dog
Will Poulter as Adam Warlock and shikuri
uji as the high evolutionary the
Guardians of the Galaxy will return for
the mcu's first ever holiday special on
Disney plus during the 2022 Christmas
season Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
will follow in theaters a few months
later on May 5th 2023.
the fast Saga has been an Unstoppable
franchise Juggernaut for years now but
things are finally starting to slow down
when it comes to the story's main
characters the upcoming 10th and 11th
installments in the series will wrap up
the story of the Toretto family and
their exciting exploits the usual major
players are back for the penultimate
installment in the series including Vin
Diesel Michelle Rodriguez Tyrese Gibson
Chris Ludacris Bridges Jordana Brewster
and Sung Kang they'll be joined by more
recent franchise editions like John Cena
and Charlize Theron in terms of
newcomers the film will also feature
Jason Momoa Brie Larson and Rita Moreno
in key roles it's also the first fast
outing for director Louis letavier who
replaced Justin Lin Midway through
production
fast X speeds into theaters on May 19
2023
Spider-Man into the spider-verse is one
of the most acclaimed superhero films of
the past decade a major animated hit for
Sony pictures that won an Oscar for best
animated future and set up a whole
Multiverse of new possibilities for its
sequel in 2023 we'll finally get to see
it for ourselves like the first film the
sequel will feature Miles Morales Peter
B Parker and Gwen Stacy teaming up as
spider-themed Heroes to save the world
but this time around they'll be getting
some new friends and enemies Oscar Isaac
has returned to play Miguel O'Hara AKA
Spider-Man 2099 a character introduced
in a post-credit scene in the first film
Issa Rae has also joined the film as
Jessica Drew more commonly known as
Spider-Woman while Jason Schwartzman
will play the Spider-Man villain known
as the spot across the spider-verse
swings into theaters on June 2nd 2023
and will be followed up by Spider-Man
beyond the spiderverse in 2024
the Transformers movie franchise just
keeps on transforming over a decade has
passed since Michael Bay launched the
live-action adaptation of the world's
favorite robots in Disguise but the
Autobots and Decepticons keep finding
new ways to make it back to the big
screen in 2023 they'll do it for the
seventh time and this time they'll be
joined by the maximals Transformers rise
of the beasts is a 90 set story that
will introduce elements of the popular
Beast Wars storyline this time around
we'll head to Brooklyn where Optimus
Prime will encounter some new faces and
face off against the vicious terracons
the Autobots won't be alone in the fight
they'll have the maximals transforming
robots who become animals along for the
ride for the first time with Ron Perlman
voicing the aptly named Optimus primal
it's a whole new frontier of
Transformers movie storytelling and it
arrives on June 9th 2023
a movie version of The Flash has been in
the works for over a decade at this
point long enough for the character to
get a whole different life on the CW
after a long list of screenwriters and
directors moved through the project
without completing it the long-awaited
DC Comics film starring Ezra Miller will
finally land in 2023. we don't know much
about the plot of The Flash yet but we
do know that it'll feature the DC
Multiverse and bring back the Batman
played by Ben Affleck and Michael Keaton
we'll also see a new live-action version
of Supergirl played by Sasha kaje
setting the stage for even more spin-off
potential that's not what actually has
people talking about the movie though I
know we're all thinking the same thing
right now
who's gonna say it I'm not going to say
it the flash has made news more recently
not for its Supporting Cast or director
Andy musketti's Vision but for Miller's
erratic behavior and frequent run-ins
with police now the question is how
Warner Brothers deals with those issues
in the lead up to the film's impending
release no matter the circumstances it
looks like we'll see the flash hit the
ground running on June 23 2023
15 years after he last appeared in a
feature film Indiana Jones will return
to the big screen for what's likely to
be the final Time starring Harrison Ford
it's been in development for years but
the still Untitled fifth Indiana Jones
film is finally on track although
director Steven Spielberg will still be
on board as a producer Indy 5 marks the
first time that the Oscar winner hasn't
directed he turned that honor over to
Logan Helmer James Mangold who also
co-wrote the script Harrison Ford who
turned 80 years old in 2022 will be
joined by mass Mickelson Phoebe Waller
Bridge Antonio Banderas Boyd Holbrook
and more not only will Harrison Ford
almost certainly be hanging up the hat
and whip but composer John Williams has
suggested that he might retire after
writing the score for Indy five it'll be
an epic return for Indy but it might
also be a farewell to two of the most
influential figures in film history
Indiana Jones 5 rolls into theaters on
June 30th 2023
the mission impossible films have defied
the odds by getting bigger and better
with each installment Tom Cruise first
played Ethan Hunt way back in 1996 and
since then he's made the character into
a kind of superhero taking on
increasingly daring real-life stunts
along the way now we're about to get the
biggest Mission Impossible yet the
seventh film in the series will once
again team Cruz with director
Christopher Macquarie The Mastermind
behind the previous two Mission
Impossibles franchise Mainstays Rebecca
Ferguson Ving Rhames Vanessa Kirby and
Simon Pegg will be along for the ride
along with series newcomers Haley Atwell
palm clementieff and Holt mcalleny
Hunt's Mission will tackle a global
conspiracy and redefine the very nature
of Truth in the public eye in 2022 Cruz
revealed that the film is subtitled dead
reckoning part 1 setting up a two-part
Adventure that won't properly conclude
until 2024. what stone is done we say
it's done Mission Impossible dead
reckoning part one finally arrives July
14 2023.
Christopher Nolan films are events unto
themselves nowadays as Nolan uses every
ounce of the cloud he won through his
Batman Blockbusters to make Grand scale
films that he might not otherwise get
the chance to tackle in September 2021
Nolan revealed that his next project
would be Oppenheimer a film about
legendary scientist J Robert Oppenheimer
and his work creating the first atomic
bombs Killian Murphy who worked with
Nolan on The Dark Knight trilogy and
Inception will play the Title Character
during his years in the Manhattan
Project meanwhile the film's massive
Supporting Cast will include Emily Blunt
Robert Downey Jr Matt Damon Florence
Pugh Rami Malek Benny safdi Josh
Hartnett Dane Dehan Jack Quaid Matthew
Modine Alden ehrenreich Kenneth Branagh
David desmulchin Jason Clark and Minnie
many more Oppenheimer will blow up the
box office on July 21st 2023.
Oppenheimer isn't the only star-studded
Blockbuster that'll be hitting theaters
on July 21st despite being based on the
brand of dolls for young girls 2023's
Barbie is gathering Buzz thanks to the
sheer number of talented people involved
Oscar nominee Greta Gerwig stepped up to
direct and co-write the film alongside
her partner fellow Oscar nominee Noah
bombach when Margot Robbie and Ryan
Gosling were announced as the future
Barbie and Ken the internet started to
get really excited we still don't know
all that much about the plot of Barbie
but set photos suggest a neon colored
aesthetic inspired by the 1990s Robbie
and Gosling will be joined by a
spectacular Supporting Cast including
simulyu America Ferreira Issa Rae Kate
McKinnon Hari Neff Michael Sarah and
Will Ferrell
phase four of the MCU has been an
interesting project so far as it's used
both feature films and its streaming
shows on Disney plus to introduce new
characters and Concepts now one of the
big payoffs for these introductions is
almost here directed by Nia DeCosta the
Marvels will unite Carol Danvers with
her best friend's daughter Monica Rambo
and the newly minted Miss Marvel Kamala
Khan my costume is near perfect just
planning the final flourish still trying
to think of that florist
beyond the cast which also includes
Samuel Jackson returning as Nick Fury we
don't know much about the film's plot
just yet of course Carol Monica and
Kamala have a lot of shared comic book
history so we can't wait to see some
Sparks Fly when the Marvels arrives on
July 28 2023. in the summer of 2023 the
dceu will get one of their most
interesting new additions yet the fan
favorite Blue Beetle directed by Angel
Manuel Soto the film will star sholo
maraduena as Jaime Reyes a teenager from
El Paso who encounters an alien artifact
that takes the form of a mysterious blue
Scarab when he interacts with it it fits
to his body and grants him an alien
exosuit with extraordinary powers
turning him into the superhero known as
Blue Beetle alongside maraduena our
co-stars Harvey Guillen Bruno marsin
George Lopez and Ronald maxtorio plus
Susan Sarandon will be starring as a new
villain created specifically for the
film Blue Beetle flies into theaters
August 18 2023.
it's been nearly a decade since the
conjuring arrived in theaters and the
franchise shows no signs of slowing down
in addition to the three films in the
main Conjuring series several spin-off
movies have now developed into
sub-franchises of their own most notably
the evil doll series Annabelle now yet
another Conjuring offshoot is set to
move into sequel territory in 2023
Warner Brothers will release the nun too
a continuation of The Saga of the
Demonic spirit valak taisa parmiga is
expected to return for the sequel as
Sister Irene a woman battling evil in
mid-20th century Europe while Bonnie
Ahrens will once again play the evil nun
director Michael shavs will Helm the
film and malignant writer Akila Cooper
will handle scripting duties valak will
be back in time for the 2023 Halloween
season arriving on September 8th of that
year
ever since Venom dropped in 2018 Sony
Pictures has been slowly building a
Marvel Universe of their own in 2023
we'll get two new installments in that
budding franchise beginning with Craven
the hunter the first big screen take on
the Title Character discussed as a
possible Spider-Man movie villain as far
back as the Sam Raimi days Craven is a
hunter who travels the world taking down
the deadliest game on the planet that
eventually leads him to Spider-Man a
powerful adversary who Craven sees as
the ultimate prey the new version of the
character may not face off against
Spider-Man but he'll be portrayed by
former Avenger Aaron Taylor-Johnson
alongside him will be Ariana Dubose as
Calypso Christopher Abbott as Foreigner
and Fred heckinger as Craven's
half-brother chameleon Alessandro navola
and Russell Crowe are also slated to
Star Craven the hunter will be on the
prowls starting October 6th 2023. after
reinvigorating the Halloween franchise
with his 2018 legacy sequel director
David Gordon green is turning his
attention to another iconic horror
series in 2020 green was announced as
the director for a new installment in
The Exorcist franchise setting the stage
for a story that will build on the
original film's tale of a young girl
possessed by a frightening evil screen
Legend Ellen burstin will return to play
Chris McNeil the mother of the young
girl possessed by the demon Pazuzu in
the first film now Chris will be called
upon to help another family whose child
is possessed possibly by the same evil
force that tried to claim her daughter
decades earlier joining Burston in the
film is Hamilton breakout Leslie Autumn
Jr who will play the father of the newly
possessed child Beyond those details we
don't know much yet but Green's
experience revisiting horror classics
makes this a project to watch out for
the film is set to release on the very
spooky date of Friday the 13th of
October 2023.
well before his first dune film was
released in the fall of 2021 filmmaker
genevil nove made it clear that he was
aiming for multiple installments his
first film was just half of Frank
Herbert's Epic Novel now thanks to the
first movie's success Dune part 2 is on
its way and it seems set to present
something even grander than its
predecessor the original film's cast are
all set to reprise their roles save for
the characters who didn't survive the
first chapter joining them this time
around are Florence Pugh who will play
Princess rulon Austin Butler as the
Harkin and fighter fade rotha
Christopher Walken as the emperor shadon
IV and Leia sedu as lady Margot the film
will pick up where the first installment
left off as Paul and treaties and his
mother joined the fremin in their fight
against the hearken invasion of Iraqis
my road leads into the desert
Dune part 2 touches down on November 3rd
2023
Aquaman's been part of the DC extended
Universe since 2016's Batman vs Superman
but he really exploded in popularity
back in 2018 when he finally got his
very own big screen solo Adventure an
Aquaman sequel was previously slated for
the 2022 holiday season but now we'll
have to wait an extra year to see
Aquaman and the lost kingdom what
exactly is the lost kingdom we don't
know for sure yet but we do know that
Jason momoa's Aquaman will be teaming up
with his disgraced half-brother Orem to
fight the powerful Black Manta we'll
also see The Return of Amber Heard as
Mira to Moira Morrison and Nicole Kidman
as Arthur's parents Willem Dafoe as
Atlantean vizier vulco and Randall Park
as marine biologist Dr Steven Shin
joining the cast for the first time are
Johnny Sao India more and pilu osbeck
plus Ben Affleck will reprise his role
as the Caped Crusader himself Batman
Aquaman and the lost kingdom will
finally reveal its secrets on Christmas
Day 2023
Martin scorsese's next film is a highly
anticipated reunion with two of his most
frequent collaborators the legendary
director has cast both The Departed star
Leonardo Dicaprio and Taxi Driver star
Robert De Niro in key roles for killers
of the flower Moon his upcoming
adaptation of the True Crime book of the
same name based on a true story the film
is set in 1920s Oklahoma and follows the
investigations into a series of murders
of Native Americans leading to the
formation of the FBI also prepare to see
Jesse plemons give the performance of
his career as he'll play lead FBI
investigator Tom white sadly we'll have
to wait a while before we can finally
watch killers of the flower Moon though
the film was originally expected to have
the 2022 Awards season run deadline
reported that the release has been
pushed back to some time in 2023
probably to give the film a world
premiere at a major Film Festival
foreign